another big Hillary Clinton lie blows up
the political scene Senator Jeff Flake
of Arizona is on his way out and he
slams the door on his way out we'll talk
about all of that i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show so a couple of
huge news items that i want to go
through today in detail give you my
perspective on them and give you a
little bit of background so that you
know what you're talking about when you
talk about it at the water cooler today
but before we get to that first i want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
helix sleep so there are a lot of places
they can get an online mattress the only
place that you should go is to my
friends over at helix sleep if you go to
helix sleep at comm slash bend you take
their simple two to three minutes sleep
quiz they ask you you know your your
height your weight your body type do you
like the mattress to be firmer do you
like to be softer do you like to be
breathability like to be kind of heat
absorbent they built a custom mattress
they'll be the best thing you've ever
slept on we had a more expensive
mattress in our bedroom and then they
sent us the helix sleep mattress and the
more expensive mattress was banished to
the other room because helix sleep is
just that good for couples they can even
personalize both sides of the mattress
everyone from GQ to Cosmo to the New
York Times are talking about helix and
you'll know why once you try it out plus
it's risk-free when your custom mattress
arrives to your door they send it to in
a box you unpack it it immediately
inflates because it's foam and shipping
is completely free you can try it for
100 nights and if you don't like it
they'll pick it up and refund you info
go to helix sleep calm slash Ben right
now and you got 50 bucks toward your
custom mattress that is helix sleep calm
/ Ben for 50 bucks off your order again
that's helix sleep calm
/ Ben they also have a bunch of other
great products like David Heelys met
helix mattress protector and the helix
foundation all these things are just
terrific products check it out over at
helix sleep comm / Ben get 50 bucks
toward your custom mattress and sleep
better at night okay so something that
may not have you sleeping well at night
and certainly doesn't have Hillary
Clinton sleeping well at night is a
story that is breaking out from the the
Washington Post last night so you need a
little bit of background to understand
what exactly is going on here so first I
have to explain you what the Trump
Russia dossier is if you remember back
to earlier this year
BuzzFeed released a dossier that was
full of information some of it more
credible than others people have been
saying that the entire dossier has been
debunked that
true some of the dossier has actually
been substantiated some of the dossier
has not the parts that were not
substantiated included the absurd
allegation that Donald Trump went to
Moscow and rented a room that the Obamas
stayed in and then had a bunch of rush
Russian prostitutes come in and pee all
over the bed right that was p8 if you
recall this it was ridiculous we made
fun of it and that of course is a not
true or at least there's no evidence to
that effect if there were then that
would be the greatest political story in
the history of mankind but it is not so
in any case that saucier comes out from
BuzzFeed earlier this year and it came
out because it had been presented the
dossier to President Trump released a
summary of the allegations had been
presented to President Trump by then FBI
director James Comey
just before Trump became president of
the United States so where did this
dossier come from the reason people were
asking this is because there were
concerns that maybe the Russians had
basically been putting out bad info and
that bad info had been used by the Obama
administration as an excuse to wiretap
all of Trump's friends right this is the
allegations the allegation is and it's
more of a conspiracy theory than an
allegation that the Russians were using
Christopher Steele basically as a cutout
this is the the spy who's responsible
for the compilation of the dossier that
he knew that the Russians were giving
him bad information he put it in the
dossier which was funded by the DNC and
the Hillary Clinton campaign that saw
CIA was then provided to the Obama FBI
and the Obama FBI used that as an excuse
to wiretap people like Carter page the
the Trump foreign policy advisor or Mike
Flynn the the one-time Trump national
security adviser that's the allegation
anyway there are a few pieces of
evidence that have to be there in order
for this allegation ultra one we have to
show that Christopher Steele the spy
actually is being played by the Russians
number two we have to show that the DNC
and Hillary knew the Christopher steel
was being played by the Russians that
would look like collusion right there
the sort of collusion that Democrats
have been accusing Trump of and three we
would have to show that the FBI in bad
faith went after people like Carter
Paige and people like Mike Flynn based
on evidence they knew was shoddy in
order to target them that contention is
is pretty extreme considering that again
if the Democrats were really focused on
just getting out bad information about
Trump then why would this dossier not
have come out and say September of 2016
like before the election it didn't so
here is the full timeline on the Trump
the Trump Russia
dossier
so Wikipedia actually has a pretty good
timeline here so I'll use that as the
basis for this in September 2015 there
was a wealthy Republican donor who
opposed to Trump's candidacy in the
Republican primary so he went to fusion
GPS and asked them to compile an apple
research file for months they did ok
then this Republicans owner after Trump
won the nomination the Republican donor
basically dropped out and that's when in
April 2016 the investigation contract
and funding was taken over by a law firm
called Perkins Coie owned by Mark Elias
or Elias he's the lawyer who represented
both the DNC and the Clinton
presidential campaign so the Hillary
campaign knew the DNC knew they Hillary
people are claiming they didn't know
that's really not credible and it was
not until after Elias came on board that
christopher Steele was hired as the
dossier compiler so the claim has been
basically that even mark Elias didn't
know Steele was the guy compiling the
dossier that's a little bit weak in June
2016 it was revealed the DNC had been
hacked by Russian sources so fusion GPS
hired Orbis business intelligence which
is a private British intelligence firm
to look into the Russian connections and
that investigation was undertaken by
Steele that's how Steele gets involved
he only gets involved after the
Democrats take over the funding for the
Trump Russia dossier he delivers his
report in a series of memos from June
through September he believed the FBI
was not taking it seriously and so it
ended up in the hands of John McCain
among other people who brought it to the
FBI and finally James Comey in January
2017 brings it to the attention of
President Trump that's the timeline on
the Trump Russia dossier so it is not
correct when that when the media say
that the Republicans funded the Steele
dossier that's not technically true they
fund at the beginning of the
investigation before Steele was involved
when the Republicans when conservatives
say that this was obvious collusion
between Hillary Clinton and the Russian
government again no evidence to that
effect in fact there is much more
evidence that the Donald Trump jr. for
example was attempting to make nice with
the Russians then that Hillary Clinton
was attempting to make nice with the
Russians at least insofar as this she
Russians in all likelihood with regards
to selling twenty percent of America's
uranium stockpile but with regards to
gathering Trump Apple Intel research not
any evidence to support that also the
idea that the FBI was acting on orders
from the Kremlin in order to get Trump
that also seems like a bit of a stretch
the reason that I lay all of this out is
because I want you to have the truth
about
what exactly is happening here I think
that there there's a lot of bit lies
being told by both sides on the left
they're saying this is no big deal at
all
you know the Oppo research shows Apple
research what's the big deal the big
deal is that if you knew and we don't
know the answer to this yet if you knew
the Oppo research was based on Russian
Intel and the Russians were funneling
that Intel to Christopher Steele then it
looks like collusion so we just don't
know the answer to that one yet on the
right the same answer applies we don't
know the answer to that one yet so you
can't assume that such collusion was
taking place in the first place so
here's what the Washington Post reported
and here's the key component okay mark
Elias apparently lied to the New York
Times about his involvement in the
dossier so apparently he told Maggie
Haberman of the New York Times who's not
involved in the compilation of the
dossier at all he suggested the DNC and
the Hillary Clinton campaign did not
fund the dossier that turns out to be
false the Washington Post reports that
last night the Hillary Clinton campaign
and the Democratic National Committee
helped fund research that resulted in a
now-famous dossier containing
allegations about president Trump's
connections to Russia and possible
coordination between his campaign and
the Kremlin people familiar with the
matter said mark Elias a lawyer
representing the Clinton campaign in the
DNC retained a fusion GPS a Washington
firm to conduct the research
after that fusion GPS hired dossier
author Christopher Steele a former
British Intel officers with ties to the
FBI and the US intelligence community so
Maggie Haberman was getting all sorts of
crap over at the New York Times because
yesterday after this came out she
tweeted out quote folks involved in
funding this lied about it and with
sanctimony for a year now it just shows
you that the rabbit left is just as bad
as some of the more rabid people on the
right that they went after Maggie
Haberman tooth and nail for the so mark
Elias lied to her she said he lied to me
and she's the bad guy but she's the
problem here Maggie Haberman who has
been thoroughly thoroughly trump
skeptical from the start in any case
says fusion GPS officials had pled the
fifth before the house Intel committee
to avoid answering funding question so
there's still questions why why was the
the DNC and why were Hillary hiding this
right that's the big question here why
what do they have to hide because they
were lying about it for months or taking
the fifth like what's the big deal why
didn't they just come up front and say
listen sure we fund it an oppo research
file sure Christopher Steele was one of
those guys so so I mean if the
implication is well they were using
foreign sources to get
their Intel we already knew that from
hillery's camp they were using the
Ukrainian government to gather for an
Intel we know that political reported it
last year so again the real question
here is as always with the Clintons what
are they trying to hide
the Clintons are so bad at covering
things up that whenever they cover
things up the cover-up ends up being
worse than the original crime right
Hillary did this with regard to the the
Whitewater papers Hillary's Hillary is
still the only first lady in American
history to be fingerprinted by the FBI
Hillary Clinton did this with regard to
her email chains right she deleted
33,000 emails then claims it was
completely innocent
every clumsy attempt to obfuscate the
truth ends up making people more and
more suspicious there's a reason to be
suspicious around here there's a reason
to be suspicious about all of this
there's also reason to be suspicious
because it's not like fusion GPS hasn't
worked at the Russians before so William
Browder is a businessman who pushed for
sanctions on Russia he's testified in
the past that the Russian government
used fusion gps before to conduct a
smear campaign against him personally
Browder admitted he couldn't connect
Russian funding to the anti-trump
dossier which means president Trump's
theory of FBI Democratic Russian
collusion is not supported by the
evidence but certain key Democrats did
apparently lie about the fusion GPS
report funding and the question is why
so that question remains in open
question
and now the Democrats are pushing back
by saying listen this is just an effort
to discredit the dossier entirely well
yes it is I mean by some people on the
right I think it is a disingenuous
effort to say that everything in the
dossier has already been discredited as
I say some of it has been discredited
some of it has not but there are serious
open questions on both side of this one
what in the dossier is true to was steel
being used by the Russians three did the
Democratic Party know that steel was
being used by the Russians and four why
did the Democrats lie about all of this
if it was just an innocent Apple
research attempt right there so here is
Adam Schiff was a very militant anti
Trump guy California representative and
he says that this entire this entire
story is just an effort to discredit
Christopher steel Christopher steel no
matter who is paying for his services
may have discovered before our own
intelligence agencies that the Russians
were going to interfere in our election
on behalf of Donald Trump so we have a
lot of work to do in terms of a lot of
the claims in the dossier
but it I don't
think it really adds much value to know
who paid for it necessarily and I view
this as part of the effort to discredit
him which really doesn't advance the
investigation okay so Adam Schiff making
the case that this is all just
obfuscation well it may all be
obfuscation but the Clinton in Minister
Clinton campaign has some questions to
answer now a lot of people are doing
this routine like well Hillary Clinton
is not president so who cares why is it
a big deal if Hillary's not not
president what exactly are you whining
about and the answer is if she'd been
president you'd be saying it's beneath
her to answer these questions so
wrongdoing is still wrongdoing and again
it does shed light on the Russian
collusion stuff if in fact it turns out
that the FBI used this dossier as the
basis to wiretap people like Carter page
and Mike Flynn and it was done in
corrupt fashion with the help of the
Russian government we just don't have
that information at this point any any
suggestions to the contrary are not true
okay any suggestions to the contrary
that this the the conspiracy theories
have been confirmed not true so let's
not get out in front of the story okay I
want to get to Jeff Flake resigning from
the Senate in just a moment but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the US concealed-carry
Association so we always hear the
stories in the news about the guy who
shoots an intruder in his house and we
think that's the end of the story right
it's all over after that no big deal
well it is a big deal because the fact
is the police are going to show up and
then they're going to ask questions
about why certain people were shot about
how you used your gun and this is why
you need to know how to talk to the
police you also need to know how to
handle a gun around the house how to
handle a gun in public scenario you will
learn in the 2017 concealed-carry and
family defense guide from the US
concealed carry Association you'll learn
how to detect attackers before they see
you how to survive a mass shooting the
safest and most dangerous places to sit
in a restaurant how to responsibly own
and store a gun even if you have little
kids and a whole lot more it's 164 pages
of great advice and knowledge that you
need about concealed carry and weapon
ownership generally it comes with a
bonus audio version so you can even
listen in your car this life-changing
guide is 100% free for a limited time
you also get a but a bonus home defense
checklist go to defend my family now
calm defend my family now calm for 100%
free instant access right now that's
defending my family now calm again
defend my family now calm okay so the
other big story of the day is the chaos
that's broke
now inside the Republican Party and it's
also it's it's all around Jeff Flake as
well as the as well as senator bob
Corker so we talked about corker
yesterday and the fact that corker is
really kind of an oozy sleazy guy and
that he and Donald Trump have now gone
at it and so corker is is in opposition
to president Trump somewhat conveniently
and has decided who's not going to run
for reelection now corker if you'd run
for reelection probably would have won
Jeff Flake is a bit of a different story
I think the story that's being told to
you by the media today is not true okay
the story that's being told to you by
the media today is basically Jeff Flake
intrepid Trump fighter struck down in
the prime of his young career because he
stood up against the nastiest man in the
universe Donald Trump Breitbart and
Trump stand ascendant over the prone
flex body as flake speaks the truth to
power that's the story that you're
getting and you're getting it from all
sides you're getting it from flakes camp
you're getting it from the Breitbart
Trump people and you're getting it from
the media and I have to say I don't
think this story is even close to the
full story so first let me express what
I think the interests are for everyone
in doing what happened yesterday so to
move back a little bit Jeff Flake
yesterday the senator from Arizona
announced he would not run for
reelection and then he gave a long
speech just ripping into President Trump
as well as Republicans who were who were
you know basically soft-pedaling
President Trump for a long time now it's
a flex you know to flex credit in terms
of consistency flake did not endorse
President Trump during the last election
cycle and was very critical of President
Trump so I'm not saying that his
opposition to President Trump is
insincere I think it is sincere but I
think the problem for for Jeff Flake is
that he knew that he was going down and
so for the past few months he's
basically attempted to carve out a
position as the anti-trump guy right the
guy who's going to earn strange new
respect from the left for saying things
about Trump now I want to be fair here
I've said a lot of the same things about
President Trump Jeff Flake says about
President Trump I agree with a lot of
what Jeff Flake says about President
Trump but the difference is that I also
compliment Trump when I think he does
something right and I also acknowledge
that people voted for Trump
not because they embraced trumpism not
because they think the trumpism should
replace conservatism but because Trump
was the only tool on hand at the time
remember Trump on a historic low
percentage of votes in the Republican
primaries to win the actual primaries he
says I'll accuse well
inside the Republican Party once he was
nominated then the Republican Party
swung behind him because he was the
nominee against the most hated Democrat
of my lifetime Hillary Clinton but that
is not the same thing that Jeff Flake is
saying what Jeff Flake basically said in
the speech is the Republican Party is a
bunch of deplorable right I mean he
basically made the Hillary Clinton
contention the Republican Party is a
bunch of deplorable as who have fallen
into league with Satan now again I think
a lot of his critiques of Trump are true
and I think that people I've been saying
for a long time people need to be
intellectually honest about what Trump
is and what Trump isn't and they ought
to call out lies and untruths and
half-truths when they see them they
ought to call out the vulgarities and
the stupidities that emanate from the
White House but that's not the same
thing as saying that all Republicans are
incapable of doing this and this seemed
to be Flakes contention Flake was
basically saying in this speech listen
the reason I'm going down is not because
of me
it's not even because of Trump it's
because the Republican Party has fallen
into disrepair that Republican
constituents my base the people who
elected me our bunch of dunderheads it's
not that they made a choice against
Hillary Clinton
it's nothing held their nose and voted
for Trump it's not even that they like
Trump but they can also critique him
it's that they have fallen full-scale
into under the sway of President Trump I
think this is a wild overstatement I
also think it's a politically convenient
one so it's play flake speech and then
I'm gonna explain what I think is really
going on so his so flake gets up
yesterday on the floor of the Senate and
he says that he is not going to run for
reelection he explains why sustained
incumbency is certainly not the point of
seeking office and there are times when
we must risk our careers in favor of our
principles now is such a time okay so he
says that now is the time for all men of
goodwill to stand up except that he's
resigning right he's not sticking around
to fight Trump's bad agenda items he's
not sticking around to to run for
reelection and try and you know wrest
control of the party away from Trump
know Jeff Flake is resigning so where
exactly is the where where is he risking
his career in favor of principles where
was the risk like this is the part that
I don't really buy okay the idea that he
risked his career to to stop President
Trump Jeff Flake has been the most
unpopular senator in the United States
Senate since 2013 okay so long before
Trump was running for president long
before he only cared about Steve Manon
long before don't care about Breitbart
okay the fact is that Jeff Flake was a
very unpopular senator pretty much from
the get-go
there's an article in the Atlantic in
2013 that was titled how Jeff Flake
became a most unpopular senator in the
United States right four years ago
before Trump was a gleam in the media's
eye or bannon's eye and Bannon wasn't a
gleam in the media's eye right the fact
is that that Jeff Flake was already
unpopular and the reason that Jeff Flake
was unpopular is because he was a hard
right congressman who won seventy-five
percent of the vote in his district for
several terms running and then he came
to the Senate and he decided to move to
the center the American Conservative
Union points out as Senator as Senator
flake score is 80% over four years as
representative his score was 98 percent
over 10 years was a 20 percent drop off
in the ACU score and it's not just that
here's a list of some of his votes Jason
Johnson who's a former Ted Cruz chief
staffer he laid out a bunch of the votes
here he suggested that that you know
it's it's well here's what he says it's
tempting to comment on flakes floor
speech instead offering context on his
view of governing by highlighting a few
of his votes Jeff Flake was one of 10
Republican senators who voted to confirm
Loretta Lynch for attorney general flake
voted to fund President Obama's
unconstitutional executive amnesty flake
voted against Senator Mike Lee's First
Amendment Defense Act flake voted for
President Obama's one point one trillion
cromnibus 2015 spending bill flake voted
for s 221 14 which increased Russia's
power at the IMF Flava flake voted for a
clean debt limit suspension flake was
one of only 11 Republican senators who
voted to confirm Janet Yellen flake
voted for the Ryan Murray budget which
lifted spending caps and raised taxes in
exchanges for promises of future
spending cuts flake voted for the gang
of eight amnesty bill flake voted for
the post newtown gun grab flake voted
against the defunding obamacare act of
2013 flake voted to increase debt by
nine hundred billion dollars in exchange
for the promise of discretionary cuts in
the future in 2011 flake preferred John
Kasich
over Cruz or Trump in the 2016 GOP
primary a so the point here is that Jeff
Flake used to be a much more
conservative guy and he moved to the
center and as he did he lost the support
of the people of Arizona but he looked
disingenuous and so he lost that support
so here he is saying that he's going
down on the burning pyre of Trump that
he's falling on his sword to done that
he's basically the monk in Vietnam
setting himself on fire to demonstrates
in the entire world just how terrible
president Trump is but that's not really
accurate Jeff Flake was going to be
primary who's going to run a very tight
I marry no matter what now his
opposition to President Trump hasn't
helped him for sure but again I think
that it's less about his opposition to
president Trump and more about his
opposition to the people who voted for
President Trump and this is a
distinction worthy of note okay you can
oppose things that Trump does you can
even say I don't think Trump makes a
very good president you can do all of
those things but what you can't do and
and what he hasn't done you know Jeff
Flake has not voted against Trump's
agenda items most of the time the vast
majority of the time Jeff Flake has
voted with President Trump's agenda
items so when he says that he doesn't
like Trump it's really more a matter of
what Trump says and what Trump does as
president not a matter of policy so how
that materializes is you can say I think
Trump is is vulgar izing the discourse I
think President Trump would be better
off if he stopped doing this stuff I
think President Trump is not a very good
president he's not doing these things
but that's not what flake does instead
flake seems to go at his own
constituents and he has been since April
basically saying the Republican Party
was subject to a takeover by a bunch of
dholtze and morons and I don't think
that that's particularly smart politics
nor do I think it's true I really don't
think that's true
I think there are a bunch of people who
voted for President Trump in the
primaries who just thought he was the
angriest guy in the stage and didn't
think beyond that which I do think is
not smart and then I think once we got
past that there were a lot of people who
voted for Ted Cruz in the primaries I
voted for John Kasich in the primaries
who also voted for Donald Trump for
presidents to stop Hillary Clinton so
flake continues along these lines and he
decides that he is going to be the one
who stands up to President Trump again I
think some of this is like posturing the
reason that I brought up his popularity
ratings and his record is to demonstrate
I think that the real story here for
flake is this flake does have sincere
opposition to President Trump he does
not like President Trump he think
President Trump is born of Vulgarian I
think some of those critiques are fair I
really do but what's really happening
here is that flake was going to lose his
primary anyway and now he sees the
opportunity to go out as the tragic hero
who sacrificed himself in order to throw
himself on the gears of the tank to stop
President Trump instead of just another
senator who wasn't particularly popular
in his home state and feels certain
things about Trump so we said now he has
an interest in basically blaming Trump
for his ouster now Trump and Breitbart
have an interest in in taking credit for
his ouster because they say listen we
run the movement now if you cross Trump
we will toss you overboard
right if you cross Trump if you cross
Breitbart we will toss you again
Kelly Ward's been running for Senate for
well over a year Breitbart only gotten
involved at the very tail end and
bannon's only getting involved now the
same thing is true in more in Alabama
Bannon and Breitbart basically backed
the guy who finished third Mel Brooks in
the primary until they switched to Roy
Moore and then they take credit I think
Jonah Goldberg has a good line about
this Bannon and Breitbart have a bad
habit when it comes to these races of
being the Rainmaker who waits for it was
the first rule of rainmaking as Jonah
says is wait for it to start raining and
then start dancing right because then
people mistake the dancing for the cause
of the rain and I think that's exactly
what's happened here so Breitbart and
Trump have an interest in saying will
you run the party now cross us and we'll
burn you down I don't think that's
actually real I don't think that's
actually true I think that you can cross
Trump pretty much with impunity actually
as long as you don't say that people who
voted for him were wrong to do so or not
understandable it was under it was a
foolish and ridiculous for them to do so
or the racist sexist big and homophobes
you sign off on everything Trump does
because they voted for him that's you
know that's lefty talk and it's not
accurate either so the Trump and ban and
I don't think are telling the truth
I don't think flake is telling the whole
truth and I think the media have an
interest in this narrative too because
it does a couple of things for them one
it allows them to create this this
perception that Trump is the evil
manipulator behind the scenes the
Palpatine behind the scenes making sure
people like bob corker and Jeff Flake
the true heroes are put to the boot and
I don't think that that's that's
interest number one and interest number
two is they like portraying the
Republican Party as split and so
anything they can do to exacerbate that
split they will do so here's Jeff Flake
going after President Trump directly mr.
president I rise today to say enough we
must dedicate ourselves to making sure
that the anomalous never becomes the
normal with respect and humility I must
say that we have fooled ourselves for
long enough that a pivot to governing is
right around the corner
a return to civility civility and
stability right behind it we know better
than that by now we all know better than
that
yes oh there it is we all know better
than no
goodies coming around the corner again
all of this is fair but I don't know why
it's effective or useful like I I think
that we all have our feelings about
President Trump but I've been highly
critical of President Trump but I do not
know what the purpose of all this is and
then and here's where he cast himself in
the role of martyr here's where he does
the Joan of Arc routine he's gonna hop
up on that pyre and light the flame he
says that you know this is not about
political savvy this is about principle
it's about principle well really about
principle you'd stick around and run for
reelection and see if you can convince
the Republican Party to agree with your
principles he's bailing out because he
knows he's gonna lose here he is now I'm
aware that more politically savvy people
that I will caution against such talk
I'm aware that there's a segment of my
party that believes that anything short
of complete and unquestioning loyalty to
a president who belongs to my party is
unacceptable and suspect okay so that
last line that did that my party
believes anything short of complete and
unquestioning loyalty to a president who
belongs to my party is unacceptable in
suspects I think it's a pretty small
segment of the party I really do I think
the bill and the chills of the party the
people who think that Trump cannot be
criticized under any circumstances I
don't think that's right I just don't
think that's true
I think there have been a number of
Senators who have criticized Trump
including Rand Paul by the way who's
gonna win his re-election easily yeah
you can criticize Trump so long as it
doesn't feel like you're ripping his
voters for voting for him again he
continues along these lines and the
martyr routine is a little bit strong
here he talks about how principled he is
even more if I have been critical it is
not because I relish criticizing the
behavior of the President of the United
States if I have been critical it is
because I believe it is my obligation to
do so and as a matter and duty of
conscience the notion that one should
stay silent and that as the norms and
values that keep America strong or
undermined and as the alliances and
agreements and ensure the stability of
the entire world are routinely
threatened by the level of thought that
goes into a hundred and forty characters
the notion that we should say or do
nothing in the face of such mercurial
behavior is a historic and I believe
profoundly misguided again
people aren't saying anything against
Trump is just absurd everyone saying
things against Trump now listen I think
some people have been cowards in this in
the situation I don't want to pretend
that everyone has been you know Paragons
of virtue here I think Paul Ryan doing
me I've never seen his tweets routine I
think that Mitch McConnell doing me I'm
just going to ignore whatever the
president says routine I think that's
wrong I think that they should speak out
but again I don't think speaking out is
the same thing as saying that you're
gonna go down simply because you spoke
out I don't think that's correct
the reason I'm objecting so strenuously
to this is because I know enough
conservatives to know that we are a
good-hearted party still that is
attempting to do the right things and I
think that criticism of President Trump
so long as it's not taken as criticism
of his voting base I think that people
are willing to go along with it I think
that what Jeff Flake is doing this is
really what I objective I feel like what
Jeff Flake is doing here is he's
surrendering the party to Trump and to
Bannon and to you know the the and to
the media's perception of what the
Republican Party is solely so that he
can look as though he's a martyr to this
new Republican Party said he can play
you know saint st. thomas becket
and against Henry Henry - like I just
don't henry ii i just don't see I don't
see the purpose of handing over the
party - I don't think this is true I
don't that I don't think that you have
to hand over the party to everything
Trump says and drawing this false
dichotomy which is really what flake is
doing here between the Bill Mitchell
wing of the party and the true speaking
wing of the party and you have to pick
one of those two I don't think that's
right I think that you don't have to
agree with Jeff Flake on everything in
order to criticize President Trump nor
do you have to say that everyone who
voted for President Trump is is going
along with every element of his agenda
in order to say that those people were
voting for for some listen I disagreed
with that vote right I didn't vote for
anyone at the top of the ticket but at
least I understood why the vote was
happening and I'm not gonna attribute
bad motivations to the people who
disagreed with me on that vote I mean
that's that's just it that's silly and
that's what I feel like flake is doing
and I've got to say it feels like some
of this is for for posturing and
personal gain considering him out with a
book called conscience of a conservative
four months ago and then did the rounds
talking about how bad Trump was in the
middle of a tough primary fight if you
want to win a primary you don't go out
there and then suggest that the party
that embraced President Trump is a nasty
terrible party what you can do instead
is you can say they were misinformed
which i think is true that they were
lied to which i think is true that there
were people who were
were preying on a justified anger which
i think is true but this is the
equivalent of you know this really is
the equivalent of remember when Hillary
was asked whether she blames women who
didn't show up to vote for her and she
said yes of course I blame them it feels
like some of this so it's convenient for
Jeff Flake to do that while he's
stepping down again this is not even me
disagreeing with flakes critique of
President Trump I don't think President
Trump has been a very good president I
think he's actually been very negative
for conservatives in a number of ways
that doesn't mean he's been that across
the board I mean as I've said Gorsuch
regulatory cuts right all these things
are good but but I think that the the
narrative that's being told to you right
now is not true and I want to explain a
little bit more about this and why
everybody is trotting out this narrative
in just a second but first I want to say
thank you to our friends over at my
patriots apply so right now if you are
looking at the news and you see there's
a wildfire in Northern California in
Southern California and hurricanes in
Florida and Texas in Puerto Rico it
seems like everywhere there's some sort
of natural disaster where the people
there would have been in good shape had
they only had some sort of emergency
food supply or at least they would have
in better shape if they had that's why
you need to prepare okay get a 102
servings survival food kit for just 99
bucks from my friends at my Patriots
supply includes breakfast lunches and
dinners it shipped to your home for free
order a kit for yourself now call eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen that's eight eight eight eight
oh three fourteen thirteen or go online
to prepare with been calm again it's
prepare with been calm the emergency
food lasts up to 25 years in storage
people in the office of tried it they
say it tastes like home cooking eight
eight eight eight oh three fourteen
thirteen or prepare with been calm again
that's prepare with been calm okay so
again the part of the problem with the
speech is not that it was just an attack
on Trump I don't care that's fine
Trump doesn't like Trump I think
deserves to be attacked sometimes I do a
relatively frequent basis on the show
but it's it's flake presenting himself
as leader if you see that the founders
were right about people the founding
fathers basically said the reason they
structured the Constitution the way they
did is because they said people aren't
ambitious people want power ambition
should therefore counteract ambition
right they should check each other if
you see ambition as a prime mover in
human motivation then you're more likely
to understand the political dynamic
every day so Jeff Flake is an ambitious
guy right he's a senator of course he's
ambitious and here he is trying to set
himself up as leader
of the sort of anti-trump conservative
resistance even though he has not been
supremely conservative as a senator by
any stretch of the imagination he and
John Kasich are sort of doing the same
thing here and if you look at Steve Ben
and he's trying to set himself up as the
leader of trumpism even though there is
no leader to trumpism because trumpism
doesn't exist there is only Zuul right
Trump is the only one who exists
trumpism is not a real philosophy if you
see that everyone is trying to set
themselves up as leader you're more
likely to understand what's going on so
here is Jeff Flake trying to set himself
up as leader in opposition to the bad
evil terrible president Trump leadership
knows that most often a good place to
start in assigning blame is to look
somewhat closer to home leadership knows
where the buck stops humility helps
character counts leadership does not
knowingly encourage or feed ugly or
debased appetites in us okay again you
know the agree with a lot of this you
know I've said it before that all
politicians pander to anger their
politicians make their Bank off of anger
but his idea that I am the leader right
that's that's the undercurrent here
leadership knows this leadership knows
that leadership know who who knows that
I know that well that's amazing look at
that coincidence he finishes up by and
this is the part where I where I have a
problem where he basically throws the
entire conservative agenda under the bus
saying I am the representative of that
conservative agenda if I cannot survive
as an anti-trump speaker then no one can
survive the party's been taking over run
for the hills I'm not ready to run for
the hills I'm not ready to surrender the
party to people who are anti free trade
I'm not ready to surrender the party to
people who are not just anti-illegal
immigration as I am but anti-immigration
generally as I am NOT right I'm not
willing to surrender the party to I
think the more basic instincts of some
people I'm not ready to do that cuz I
don't think that's my party I don't
think that's my movement maybe I maybe
maybe Jeff Flake is right maybe it's
time for despair you know there's a lot
of despair I think in the in the
conservative the traditional
conservative movement that the party has
been soul sucked I feared that that was
gonna happen when Trump took office I
feared a little less now I don't think
that the party has been soul sucked I
don't think every conservative has
become a Trumpkin on every issue
I think that conservatives as I've said
before see President Trump is a litmus
test that if you are going to say that
that Trump is is awful terrible no good
very bad
evil and unjustifiable and that any vote
for him was a bad vote if you're gonna
say that then that's not a referendum on
Trump that's a referendum on all the
people who voted for him it's the
Hillary Clinton deplorable line all over
the ghin you know I think that that is
is a point that people are using Trump
to elucidate I think people are using
Trump is a bit of a litmus test but you
can still oppose Trump when he does
things that are wrong you can still
speak up when he does things that are
stupid and I think constituents mostly
understand that because a lot of
Congress people do that but here is the
the final thing that Jeff Flake says
that I ripped again this is the part I
really disagree with this is why I think
his motivations here are not entirely
sterling it is clear at this moment that
a traditional conservative who believes
in limited government and free markets
who is devoted to free trade who is Pro
immigration as a narrower and narrower
path to nomination in the Republican
Party the party that has so long defined
itself by its belief in those things it
is also clear to me for the moment that
we have given in or government given up
on the core principles in favor of a
more viscerally satisfied anger and
resentment to be clear the anger and
resentment that the people feel at the
Royal mess that we've created are
justified but anger and resentment are
not a governing philosophy there is an
undeniable potency to a populist appeal
by mischaracterizing or misunderstanding
our problems the impulse to scapegoat
and belittle threatens to turn us into a
fearful backward looking people okay so
I agree with a lot of the statements
that he's making about the appeal to
anger I've said the exact same thing on
this show I don't disagree with him but
it's that set it's that first second
that first sentence Ted that bothers me
the anger and the resentment he's right
they are not a governing strategy but he
himself is suggesting that they are
replete with a particular philosophy and
I don't think that's right I don't think
that's true the same anger and
resentment that drove the Tea Party to
victory based on a small government
platform drove President Trump to
victory based on a populist platform
because anger does not have any
philosophy to which it attaches
exclusively anger it can be
anti-establishment gore and that's what
we're watching and that's why I have
hope for the future of the conservative
movement
because I think that that anger can be
turned and should be turned toward the
right things not the wrong things I
think president Trump has turned things
toward the wrong things I think he's
turned anger toward things that are
unjustified I think that he has excused
bad behavior I think that he has made
the case on philosophically false
grounds that the American people are
being screwed by people who really have
nothing to do with it I think all of
those things are true but the idea that
that that represents that the the
trumpism is the final iteration of
Americans anger that trumpism is the
final stage of Republican anger I don't
think that's right I think Trump was the
most convenient angry guy at their
disposal and they picked them and it's
that simple it's not that they have
rejected limited government and free
markets it's not that they've rejected
limited government in free markets I
agree that anger cannot be the prime
motivator for conservative thought but
to suggest that anger has become that
prime motivator and Trump is the sole
evidence you need and Jeff Flake sastras
of the sole evidence you need is
self-serving in a little bit
hypocritical ok so I want to talk more
about this plus things I like things I
hate a little bit of bible talk but for
that you're gonna have to go over to
Daley wire calm for just $9.99 a month
you can get a subscription to Daley
wire.com get the rest of the show live
on video get the rest of Michael
Knowles's show live on video get the
rest of Andrew kleavon's show live on
video you can part of our mail bags as
well and correspond with us when we do
conversations we do this every month we
we take just nothing but questions for
an hour hour and a half and you can ask
the questions if you are a member
plus if you want an annual subscription
you get all those things plus this
leftist here is hot or cold tumblr which
is the greatest beverage vessel ever
created by human or godly hands it is
just incredible again the big mistake
that the that the bad guy makes and
Indiana Jones and the and the Last
Crusade is that he does not pick this
mug had he done so then all would have
been well and his face would not have
fallen off and he wouldn't have turned
into a horrible horrible looking
skeleton so for $99 a month you can get
all of those things plus this particular
mug and the Shapiro store is coming I
keep saying it it's coming okay it is I
promise I've seen the gear also if you
we recommend highly that you go and
subscribe to to our channel on youtube
so if you're watching this on youtube
right now just click on daily wire right
there and subscribe we have plenty of
other content that is coming out from
daily wire that is not just our shows
shorts digital shorts
all sorts of really great stuff videos
from my my college speeches all that
stuff is available at our daily wire
accounts over at youtube so please go
over there and subscribe or listen later
at iTunes or SoundCloud for free
obviously and you can do that on YouTube
as well leave us a review we always
appreciate it we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so now I'm going to show you that and
now I'm gonna show you why everyone has
an interest in pushing the false
narrative that what happened here was
not a senator who's going to lose bowing
out and then putting that in the best
possible light by attacking President
Trump again not in sincerely but a
little bit politically cynically instead
we've gotten this narrative Jeff Flake
fallen hero Donald Trump villain who put
him out and everybody basically has the
the same take because it's convenient
for all of them so here's the Huffington
Post headline right huffington post
headlined this yesterday there's the
HuffPost big banner headline yesterday
bannon's storms the desert right it's
Bannon who took out Jeff Flake nonsense
nonsense I worked at Breitbart okay this
is crap it's crap Ola Kelly Ward was
running against Jeff Flake for well over
a year before banning even knew how to
spell Arizona ok this idea that the
Breitbart was the was the soil mover
here is a creation of the media because
the media love this story right they
want it to be a fight for the soul of
the party between two bad guys that's
their goal right the losers are all the
good honest noble men the people for
whom the media have a strange new
respect right Jeff like strange new
respect pence a strange new respect Ben
Shapiro strange new respect right
there's this idea that anytime you
oppose Trump strange new respect from
the media the media have an interest in
promulgating that narrative because what
they want is the people who are losing
are the people for whom they have
strange new respect the good folks the
people have been exiled from the party
and the people who are winning it's
Steve ban and his white nationalist
brute squad right there are the people
who are winning so Huffington Post is
happy to push that of course so his
Breitbart so Breitbart immediately post
the HuffPo headline as its own headline
saying look even HuffPost says this of
course HuffPost says this i mean they
have an interest in pushing this Trump
has an interest in pushing this Jeff
Flake has an interest in pushing this I
think everyone is misinterpreting here I
think it's a big mistake
right Ari Fleischer who typically his
political analysis is is pretty pretty
good but you know when he says this is a
win for Trump and Bannon in what sense
is it a win for Trump and banette I mean
it's quite possible that Kelly Ward
loses loses the Senate race and then
Trump loses the seat in Arizona and
again you can't pin this one on Trump
because Jeff Flake was you know the
lowest rated senator among his home
state contingent of any senator
for years before any of this happened
look at events today and not declare
that Donald Trump wants to ban in one
the fact of the matter is the people
they like lease the establishment
organizations inside people inside the
Republican Party are not running for
re-election because Donald Trump has
helped chase them out of the party but
go back in time it's it is true you go
back to the primary and 16 candidates
many of them cut from the same cloth as
corker and then a flake couldn't compete
with Donald Trump Ted Cruz and Donald
Trump got 80% of all Republican votes
cast in that primary the establishment
candidates got less than 20% state by
state by state from the beginning to the
very end so now you are seeing that
manifestation of it play out in the
Senate would I have a hard time wrapping
my I am I my mind around is they said
you must fight you must stop you must
stand up to President Trump but then
they don't run it seems to me if you
feel that fervently about standing up to
fight then you go through your primary
and you prove that you can move
Republicans to your direction but
instead of fighting they the last part
of what Fleischer is saying there but
what I hate is that is the the
combination where he says that what he
just sort of slips that an 80% of the
primary vote went to Trump and Cruz yes
and crews had policy prescriptions that
are precisely the opposite of trumps in
many of these cases and he was running
heavy percentages of the vote as a
really unattractive candidate I said
then that which again shows that Trump
is the avatar of the anger but he is not
the new philosophy of the Republican
Party I'm not willing to surrender the
party that Jeff Flake is this is my
biggest objection with Jeff Flake what
Jeff Flake did yesterday is he basically
said the party is now Trump's party the
party is not Trump's party Trump is just
the figurehead for a party and he's a
figurehead of the inn but Jeff Flake had
every right to be in the Senate just as
Trump has to be in the White House and
the idea that Jeff Flake is sort of
responsible for that the Donald Trump is
these the final iteration is just
silliness it's not it's not true Trump
is not and again conflating his
popularity and his ideology would be a
big mistake and a not true one it's just
not true okay time for some things I
like things I hate and then we'll do a
little Bible talk so things I like so
today's things I like is a podcast
called another Kingdom this is a
fictional podcast put together by our
very own Andrew Clavin and perform by
our very own Michael moles it is not
actually a daily wire project one of the
reasons for that is because it is
fleet with cursing but it's it but but
it is really entertaining it's really
well done Knowles acts at Clavin wrote
it and the basic premise is that there
is a Hollywood failed Hollywood
screenwriter who stumbles into a doorway
that leads him a portal that leads him
into basically a fantasy knights and
maidens world and it's it's really well
written it's really fun to listen to
it's not you know old radio drama in the
sense that you have like the the cheesy
squeaking sounds of the shoes on the
pavements or anything but it's it's
great to listen to and it's getting good
numbers go and check another Kingdom and
go subscribe to it and I think ricochet
puts it out and even do that at iTunes
or SoundCloud as well and I Andrew
Clavin to another Kingdom performed by
our very own Michael Knowles who
shockingly has the capacity to to act
actually I was I was surprised by that
considering our interactions in the
theatrical sense here at the office
because so far I've not seen the acting
chops but he shows them he shows them in
another kingdoms to check it out okay
time for some things that I hate so it's
virtue signaling all around Kathy
Griffin has decided to disown her former
her former disowning of her beheading of
Donald Trump so you recall that she
infamously held up a beheaded sort of
mock-up of trumps head with blood
dripping over the face and in in almost
Isis fashion and she was casting it in
floor she lost her job at CNN for it on
New Year's Eve and now Kathy Griffin is
back at it and she's saying Trump's a
psycho she's trying to earn her way back
in and it'll be fascinating to see
whether the Hollywood elite accept her
back in I think there's a good chance
that they will because you know as time
heals all wounds it looked bad in the
moment that she was beheading President
Trump but they really hate President
Trump down deep - so she'll probably
start going to all the good cocktail
parties again here she is calling
President Trump a psycho
these Trump folks they self-identify as
deplorable it's like as if that's a good
thing and there are psychos I mean
they're not so I'm here to apologize I'm
sorry that we have put this guy on
everybody else's lap and I don't know
what's happening in my own country
you know when Kathy Griffin says things
like you know they call themselves
deplorable the reason they say they're
deplorable is is because they're mocking
Hillary Clinton who said that half of
all Trump voters are racist sexist big
at homophobes you hate the poor I mean
let's be real about that
and does she think that she's winning
anyone over to her side again I think
that very few people in the country
right now
are focused on winning over new converts
their side again this is my objection to
Flake speech I don't think Flake speech
wins people over to his side I think
Flakes speech actually alienates a lot
of the people he's attempting to reach
out to and I think he had a habit of
that which is why he was losing his
Senate race to Kelly Ward in an
osteopathic physician who apparently has
questioned the validity of chemtrails
before you know like I just don't I I
the the virtually signaling has to stop
from all sides is just it's virtually
signaling like try to convince someone
it's so funny you know I get ripped in
the press I got ripped in the New York
Times for quote-unquote not trying to
convince people I would bet dollars to
donuts that we have more leftists in
liberals who listen to this program then
who listen to the vast majority of other
conservative programs and I would
guarantee you that the number of
products that I pursued that I
personally have endorsed and said people
should go read on things I like from the
left is much higher than it would be on
some shows of the left because I think
it's interesting to read the other side
Kathy Griffin isn't interested in having
the conversation she's interested in
calling people Nazis again this is how
you got Trump another way you got Trump
is stupidity like this there's this
protester who showed up at the Senate
yesterday and President Trump was
walking through with a turtle turtle man
Mitch McConnell and here's the protest
threw a protester throwing Russian flags
at President Trump
[Applause]
okay so that guy of course was it was
very happy to all the attention what I
hate about this is not the guy throwing
the flags because that's dumb but you
know it's America it's free speech is it
great that he's doing that right in
front of the president not particularly
but I'm not gonna lose any sleep over it
what I do love is look at how the
media's cameras shift right they're
following Trump down the hall and then
immediately they all flip their cameras
and you can see one of the cameramen
sort of grinning at the guys screaming
Trump is treason you know the media eat
this stuff up
they love the polarization it's their
favorite thing instead of focusing on
what unifies us the media have an
interest in driving us apart okay final
thing that I hate Paul Ryan says that
the DREAM Act the new DREAM Act is gonna
be part of the spending bill once again
I hate omnibus bills I hate them the
idea that in order for me to fund
defense I have to fund the DREAM Act
green cards for so-called dreamers it's
it's absurd it's absurd and it's another
broken promise from conservatives who
said they were gonna stop Obama's
executive amnesty not that they were
going to reinforce Obama's executive
amnesty on the legislative level
okay so one's a liberal Bible talk today
so I've decided to change the format of
Bible talk instead of just taking
whatever the Jews happen to be reading
this week I'm going to just give a
biblical thought that has been occurring
to me because I do spend a fair bit of
time thinking about the depth of the
Bible so a couple of weeks ago we
started reading the Torah again in the
Jewish community
we had the holiday of Simchat Torah
where we celebrate the the finishing of
the cycle of reading the Torah and then
we start reading again from the
beginning so we read the first chapters
of Genesis
so the parsha itself is Bray she'd and
in the beginning and and I have a read
on the tree of good and evil knowledge
of good and evil that I think is kind of
interesting at the very least so here I
want to pose two ideas that are sort of
an opposition one is the idea of
Aristotelian good and the other is the
idea of moral good these are not the
same thing so the way Aristotle thought
of something being good was the way that
you would think of a watch being good
right or hamburger
or hamburger being good what makes
something good in the Aristotelian view
is it's it is that it is fitted to its
purpose right my watch is good my my MVM
to watch right here this this watch is
good because it tells time and looks
good right that is its job and so it is
good at being a watch right you're
you're good at being a radio host if you
can get listeners you're good at being a
senator if you are capable of exercising
independent judgement and acting on
behalf of the interests of the United
States right that's what makes you good
at things and you are a good person
according to Aristotelian thought if you
fulfill the function of a human which is
to think and reason right this is
basically Aristotle's notion of good and
then virtue is all the qualities that
you have to that you have to push in
yourself so that you can achieve these
Heights of reason and rationality that's
that's Aristotelian good moral go to
something different moral good is the
idea that we determine of our own sort
of our own thinking what is a good thing
to do and what is a bad thing to do what
is a moral thing to do and what is an
immoral thing to do it has little to do
with purpose itself it has to do more
with our moral intuition this I think is
what the Bible is trying to tell us at
the very beginning so at the very
beginning of the Bible when God says let
there be light and then there's light
and then God says it says and God saw
that the light was good it was evening
and it was morning the first day right
when it does that when it says and God
saw that it was good what does it mean
it was good doesn't mean the light was
morally good what did the light do to
earn that sort of moniker right says it
was told it was good
what did is it was good at being a light
right it fulfilled its purpose it was
fitted to its purpose right everything
that the the on the first six days the
only thing that is not considered fitted
to its purpose is the separation of the
firmaments the separation of the waters
on day two but everything else is
considered fitted to its purpose right
it is toe then we get into the Garden of
Eden man has now been created and God
says here's the tree of life and here's
the tree of good and evil you know he
says you can eat from the tree of life
he never tells people not to eat from
the tree of life right wait for all we
know Adam and Eve we're eating from the
tree of life regularly because he never
forbids them from doing that
he only forbids them from eating from
the tree of the knowledge of good and
evil okay the word evil only pops up its
head for the first time in this context
and what the Torah is saying here is
it's contrasting the idea of tove
meaning fitted to its purpose from good
and evil in moral terms and what it's
saying is if man would think in terms of
what purpose are you fitted for what
purpose did God fit you to you'll live a
happier more complete life than if you
are making up your own standards of
right and wrong right your subjective
standards of right and wrong now God has
implanted his morality in the world as
the idea here right he has implanted his
morality can be discerned by discerning
purpose that's the idea of the original
good but the tree of knowledge of good
and evil says the man can create his own
perceptions his own subjective
perceptions of what it is that's good
and evil right this morally relativistic
perspective and so what is the natural
punishment for that once you've done
that once you've decided that you're
going to take the world that God created
ignore his purpose and make your own
then everything falls out of kilter
right you're not actually acting in
accordance with nature you're no longer
acting in accordance with how nature is
supposed to work so what happens God
says it's not a curse it's not that
God's angry
God says the natural consequence of you
eating from the tree of good and evil is
that you can no longer live forever in
the sense that you're not now a part of
nature you're something separate from
nature judging it as something apart
from nature for it's good and moral
content and also the earth will not
yield you its fruit right you're gonna
have to work for a living
childbirth is going to be painful right
I'm sure childbirth was painful before
the eating from the tree but the idea
was that that was part of the purpose
right part of the purpose was the pain
because the pain is what allows you to I
mean it's the cramps that push the baby
out right is the uterus easing up that
pushes the baby up we understood that
but now all of a sudden we recognized
pain as evil we recognize work as an
evil and so now stuff that was just
considered natural and purposeful is
considered an evil so we start seeing
things in darker terms and that's what
happens that's the transition it's not
that human beings become inherently evil
it's not the original sin is that we now
become sinful it's that before when you
are acting in accordance with God's
purpose as we were before acting in
accordance with the Aristotelian notion
of God's good when you do that then you
are always going to be acting with good
and sin doesn't become an issue but sin
becomes an issue as soon as we start
substituting our own judgment for God's
in terms of not purpose of good but in
terms of what we personally think is
morally good for us because we're not
the final judges of that God made us we
did not make God and we did not make the
morality that God created and embedded
in the universe okay
we'll be back here tomorrow with more
deep thoughts like that and presumably
more fallout from all the political
matters of the day I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]